mmm oh my god Oh
[Music]
I'm always preaching meat cheese and fun
on the show but today I'm focusing on
something equally important veggie
burgers we're in a golden era of
plant-based patties which is why I
invited actress and veggie burger
superfan Lana Condor for the ultimate
veggie burger taste test the star of
Netflix's rom-com to all the boys I've
loved before is gonna judge some of the
best-in-class veggie patties and see if
my own version can setup to the test
Lana Condor welcome thank you go to the
burger show I'm ready welcome to my
beautiful restaurant here no lead of the
usual I can't believe this
I know you're like this huge actress but
I follow you on Instagram watched her
Instagram stories and you're also like a
part-time food blogger oh my god it's my
it's my true passion you love food I do
I do I love it I love it more than more
than anything right well you know what I
love more than anything in this world
it's like therapy look at that flapper
this is like our fourth season yeah and
I've developed like a credo it's meat
cheese and fun right but today I'm
veering off track I know right we're
gonna do veggie burgers I'm so ready I'm
so excited
right well because you're you're a
pescetarian yeah I'm a pescetarian I've
actually never eaten like an a proper
real burger ever in my life right um so
I don't have much to compare it to but
the veggie burgers that I like I do love
the impossible burgers like the beyond
me I love that and and and just like all
the cheese um since all the mustards
everything right if it's like very like
grainy it's not my favorite we really
want to show that veggie burgers aren't
just for vegetarians right and I think
that's a true testament of a good veggie
burger is if a meat-eater will be like
oh damn and that's me that was dope
we're taste two of what I feel are the
best in class in New York plus I'm gonna
roll out the red carpet and I'm gonna
make you a surprise veggie burger that
I've created
we're gonna start with burger number one
okay
have my bell here okay
Kim burger number one please oh yes this
is uh this is Kim you psyche my Alfred
to my Batman oh my god what is more like
mrs. Doubtfire oh great
dude what was that what do you mean why
are you wearing a bear suit I just
wanted to give everyone a nice little
giggle
who is it hey guys I need this in about
10 minutes this is the superiority
burger so has a Martin's potato roll as
Munster cheese which is a nod to his
chef hood iceberg lettuce roasted tomato
that brown honey mustard and the patties
made with quinoa chick peas carrots
walnuts and breadcrumbs so chef Brooks
Headley is a former drummer for punk
bands
he's also award-earning pastry chef okay
so like if you're gonna make a dope
veggie burger spot like that's like the
mathematics seriously whoa that is like
that's amazing there's a cult following
to it what's awesome about this burger
is that like the ingredients are sourced
from the farmers market it's like the
same as like fancy-pants restaurants oh
wow but it's only six dollars it's a
nice thick style thanks yeah the chef is
for the people oh my god I'm here for
that right I have really high
expectations
nice dress oh oh
I took a hug that's good right
so he has what I think is good right the
texture mm-hmm it has like the
earthiness I like that it's not falling
apart yeah cuz I drink some with some
veggie burgers especially when they have
like creams I guess probably yeah right
but this isn't really sticking together
it's not trying to be fake meat
she's walking a walk you definitely when
you when you look at it and even when
you hold it you feel like the craft of
it right but how hard yeah and like when
you you don't have to convince anyone
after you eat this very like to you
there's a line out the door and this is
kind of where all the cool
mm-hmm I gotta say I'm trying to
unthinkable all the veggie burgers proud
of my life this has gotta be like
definitely like up there you literally
like top two right I just love how easy
to eat all right so this is burger
number two this is the shroom burger
from Shake Shack boys
it's a portobello mushroom stuffed with
cheese breaded and pan-fried this veggie
burger for me is like the best
mainstream yeah
veggie burger because again you don't
have to be a vegetarian to like this I
totally agree and the crispy and then it
uses out yeah it's genius
to me this is what I think is a
vegetarian Juicy Lucy I don't know if
you're familiar with that Wow but don't
I think there was a Lucy a guy ran into
a bar Matt's bar in Minneapolis and he
said make me something different and the
time the bartender the owner he said
okay how about I put some cheese between
two patties let go so good and
apparently he took one bite of the
burger and a burned his face listen whoa
that's one Juicy Lucy like a calzone I
love this thing so much I was like
squish it first
mmm mmm this when I have the fries
mm-hmm I take the fried I'm gonna stuff
it in there and take the cheese out this
is the only veggie burger that's made
out of like simply like a portobello
mushroom that I've enjoyed they make it
I think it's the next level yeah I also
think that this is the most pain one can
feel when eating food because sometimes
when you go it's the cheese is so hot
and then you go in and it just like
squirts out but it's worth it that's
like that common this flavor for all
juicy Lucy's across the world beware
beware
we've tried to of the best-in-class
veggie burgers now I'm gonna roll the
red carpet beautiful and I'm gonna make
you my very own veggie burger I'm so
excited to do this here we are we're
gonna make my veggie burger okay this is
inspired by my finals week in culinary
school okay and one of our instructors
is like I'm gonna give you a recipe it's
gonna suck I looked at him and I was
like I get me anything tastes good you
know hot yeah the recipe was for a
pre-colonial grain pancake I made this
aced it and everyone's like dude just
turn into a burger yes over the
last 10 years this has been kind of in
my recipe books it has Pharaoh as black
beans onion powder garlic powder salt
pepper coriander cumin and peanut butter
I'm so interested about the paper
because I have never had peanut butter
on me yeah and then for the umami we
have shiitake mushrooms cremini
mushrooms that I roast so they're almost
like chips and then I can rise it and
create like a mushroom dusts you form it
into a puck and you sear it
this is the Marg potato roll cheryl-lea
kind of overcooked the farro yeah so
that you're like puffs out yeah and what
happens when you when you fry it it gets
like this like crispy almost like
chicharonnes feel to it yeah what
exactly we're selling
that's cumin that's a cubed okay mate
coriander they have an affinity for each
other I create this like really
delicious almost like punch you in the
face zest eNOS and this what's this
that's cashew cheese that's my new thing
really yeah so living in New York I
realized so many people are non-dairy
this is more like a so we put like
called
really it was kind of a little spicy
yeah it's like Southwest Texas almost
flavors guy spotlight sure
cilantro Mayo
we have shredded lettuce and then last
but not least this is roasted tomatoes I
want you there you go boy oh my gosh I'm
nervous I'm nervous you meat cheese bun
okay I can fall back on that if this
sucks no it's not going to I'm ready I'm
looking film in here no here
[Music]
right oh right you can taste the
mushrooms yeah you have the coriander
the you taste a peanut butter for sure
yeah that's shocking what but it's not
overpowering what it's a bar it's not
that hard
oh wow I just I can held it ha ha I mean
it this is amazing the thing that makes
us stand like apart I think to me it's
very very creamy but freaking love this
oh yes you know that just like does it
for me
thank you for joining me on this
fantastic veggie voyage thank you yeah
you did ha ha ha thank you for joining
us um it was a pleasure having you on
the burger show
[Music]
you